- [Narrator] As we've talked
about in multiple videos,
Christianity is a religion
that grew out of the
fringes of the Roman Empire.
It starts as a Jewish
sect in Judea and Galilee
with the teachings of Jesus
and his early ministry.
But it's important to keep in mind
that at the time of Jesus's crucifixion,
around 30 C.E., he only had, at most,
we're talking about in
the hundreds of followers.
But in other videos, we
talk about his apostles
who start spreading the faith,
not only to other Jews,
but also to non-Jews, to gentiles.
We talked about Emperor Nero
and his famous purges of Christians,
in particular, you have
the famous Roman Fire,
or The Fire of Rome in 64 C.E.
that Nero blames on Christians,
and he uses this to do
significant purge in Rome.
Many historians believe that
the apostles Peter and Paul
were killed during those purges.
This is a painting of
Nero using Christians
lighting them alive to
punish them for that fire.
Now, other imperial acts that continue
to have a significant effect
on this very early Christian church.
We talked about the destroying
of the second temple
in Jerusalem in 70 C.E.,
and that's under the reign of Vespasian.
And this of course is a
very significant event
for the Jewish people,
but it also has a significant
effect on Christianity,
because remember Christianity was really
centered at Jerusalem.
It was a sect of Christianity,
or it was, it got its start
as a sect of Christianity,
but now, with the
destruction of the temple,
the Jews were dispersed from Jerusalem,
and so were many of
these early Christians.
And so the centers of Christianity
became throughout the empire,
places like Antioch.
And you continue to have a
discomfort with Christians
especially as they became
more and more in number,
and they started to have
more and more power.
And here you have these people
who refused to obey the Roman gods,
to do their rituals, to
worship the Roman gods,
and remember, even, there
was emperor worship here.
And the issue was more so
than even the Jewish people,
who, to a certain degree,
kept to themselves,
these Christians were missionaries.
They were spreading their
faith to Roman citizens.
Families were being split apart,
where some decided to become Christians
and no longer follow
these Roman practices.
And so you have these
various persecutions,
and these various purges,
and they get more and more significant
as you go into the second
and even to some degree
in the third century
as Christians become
more and more prominent
and more and more in number.
Remember, they have this missionary zeal,
and it really becomes a significant purge
under the reign of Diocletian.
In previous videos, we
talk about Diocletian.
He's the one that
famously split the empire
between east and west,
but he's also famous for
his purge of the Christians.
The most extreme state-sponsored
purges of Christians
in the Roman Empire.
But what's interesting is right after,
or shortly after those purges,
we're talking a few decades here,
the next empire that would,
the next emperor who would have reign
over the entire Roman Empire,
would be Constantine,
and at least relative to Christians,
he would be the opposite of Diocletian,
because as he's trying
to consolidate his power
in 312 C.E.,
you have the famous battle
at the Milvian Bridge
outside of, or entering into Rome.
And in this battle, Constantine,
he sees a vision of the Christian cross
centered on the sun,
and he thinks that that is a sign
that he should fight under the cross.
And he gets the symbols painted
on his soldier's shield,
and he's victorious.
This date, 312, Milvian Bridge,
The Battle at Milvian Bridge,
is viewed as the beginning
of Constantine's
conversion to Christianity,
viewing it as his chosen faith.
In 313, the Roman emperor, or the empire,
issues the edict of Milan,
which officially makes Christianity OK.
It legalizes Christianity,
which is a big deal,
because these folks have been
persecuted all this time.
They haven't been
worshiping the Roman gods.
Then in 325, Constantine
goes even further,
and he convenes the council of Nicea,
where he brings the bishops
from all of Christendom together,
to start having a more
unified belief system.
They come up with a Nicean creed.
A lot of the debate is whether Jesus,
as son of God, should be
considered equal to God
or as God or a little less,
as being the son,
maybe if he is the son,
maybe there was a time
where there wasn't a son,
and there was just God,
but the Nicean Creed says no,
they are one and the same,
these two things are equivalent.
And then Constantine, on his death bed,
famously gets baptized,
and becomes a Christian,
the first Christian emperor
of this gigantic Roman Empire.
And so you can imagine,
you have more and more
followers of Christianity,
but now, this is, so to speak, prime time.
The emperor of the Roman,
the emperor of the Roman Empire
has converted to Christianity,
and it's a legalized religion.
And then that gets even more momentum
when we get to the end
of the fourth century.
Emperor Theodosius, who is Christian,
under him, it becomes
the official religion
of the Roman Empire,
the same empire that at one point,
Christianity was illegal,
and it was being persecuted,
now it was the official religion
of the Roman Empire.
Theodosius, I mention him in other videos,
he was incidentally also the last emperor
to rule over both Eastern
and Western Roman Empires.
So you have this empire that
starts off very anti-Christian,
actually in the beginning,
they don't really take much
note of what's going on
in Judea and Galilee,
but more and more, they
start to persecute them.
But we go a few hundred years into this,
and it becomes a Christian empire.